NARRATOR: Historically,
shark attacks on Reunion
have been rare.
Over the previous decade,
the annual average
was just one incident.
But in 2011, the
island is in crisis.
Mathieu is actually Reunion's
fifth victim this year.
And it's only September.
Islanders are in shock.
It's vitally important
that we find out
the reasons for these attacks.
There is a real problem here.
LORIS GASBARRE: We noticed
that something was changing.
What?
We didn't know.
NARRATOR: Residents are
desperate for answers.
Their safety and their
livelihood is at stake.
LORIS GASBARRE: A small
island lives with tourism.
If we don't have
tourism tomorrow,
we'll have nothing left.
NARRATOR: So what's triggering
this deadly spate of attacks?
To find out, the French
government calls in leading
shark expert Geremy Cliff.
Clearly alarm
bells were signaling.
Five shark attacks of
which two were fatal.
That is a huge spike.
NARRATOR: Cliff believes
the first step to solving
this mystery and
preventing further attacks
is to identify the
species responsible.
So he starts by analyzing
Mathieu's incident.
And a chilling
details stands out.
He was attacked by two sharks.
MALE: [speaking french]
NARRATOR: A double shark attack
like this is extremely rare.
In fact, it's thought that
such an event has only
been captured on film once.
In the year 2000
in South Africa,
a teenager is surfing, when
he's suddenly knocked off
his board by one shark
while a second shark
attempts to bite him.
Incredibly, the boy survives.
But this tag-team tactic
may serve as a calling card
for the culprit in Reunion.
GEREMY CLIFF: Only certain
shark species hunt together.
NARRATOR: Hammerheads search
for food in large schools
that can consist of
more than 100 sharks.
And lemons conduct
coordinated assaults
by herding prey into one area.
Even blacktips hunt in
groups in the shallows.
But Cliff thinks
these species are all
too small to inflict
the kind of damage
that caused Mathieu's death.
GEREMY CLIFF: One of
the striking features
of this particular attack is
the severe injuries involved.
NARRATOR: Such ferocity points
to a much larger predator.
And only two species
commonly found in the region
fit that bill.
GEREMY CLIFF: Firstly,
we have the tiger shark.
Tiger sharks reach
at least 16 feet.
They have the size, in
terms of jaws and body size
to be able to tackle large prey.
And therefore, they won't be
scared of attacking a human.
NARRATOR: Yet, Cliff
doubts tigers are to blame.
They are totally
solitary animals
and will hunt on their own.
NARRATOR: That leaves
only one possible culprit.
To explain, Cliff turns to
footage recently captured off
the coast of Reunion, as part
of a study on the behavior
of the region's sharks.
It depicts one particular
species that apparently
plays well with others.
GEREMY CLIFF: It shows clear
evidence of two sharks swimming
together, one behind the other.
In fact, in nearly 20% of
occasions captured on film,
they were seen
foraging together.
The sharks seen here
are bull sharks.
NARRATOR: Bull sharks
weigh as much as 500 pounds
and are highly aggressive.
They typically attack on their
own, often head-butting prey
before tearing it to shreds.
But as these images
reveal, they also
use another hunting tactic.
GEREMY CLIFF: There's
clearly an advantage
to work cooperatively
and thereby
prove predation efficiency.
NARRATOR: Based
on this evidence,
Cliff believes he's
identified the type
of shark that killed Mathieu.
GEREMY CLIFF: So
from that I would
conclude that a bull
shark was responsible
for this particular attack.